hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that they just finished
from the final round of the 2022 tata
still chess tournament the tournament is
now over all of the games have finished
and before we check out this game uh i
would just like to mention something
yesterday in the pre in the last video
that i made i i mentioned that daniel
might be playing magnus today if he is
allowed to play uh but for those of you
who still don't know uh this is the uh
tweet by the tata still chess uh twitter
account daniel dubovo tested positive
for kovid19 on thursday
a second test requested by dubois
himself showed a negative result the
dutch health authorities stipulated that
in these circumstances the positive test
result stands and supersedes the
negative outcome hashtag tata still
chest saying that it doesn't matter if
he's texted negative if he only tested a
positive once then that's the the result
that we are going to consider so that's
why there was no game today and the
magnus got a full point and of course
won the tournament yeah so as soon as i
uploaded yesterday's video i i saw the
news on twitter so i couldn't revert it
i did post it in the comments but maybe
some of you missed it so now getting
back to this game uh okay
i could have chosen uh many games but i
chose this one as it features again
another nimzo indian uh and again we go
for the a3 line not the queen c2 or the
e3 line and it's a very very enjoyable
like the one that jordan played against
aneesh so here uh prague with the white
pieces opens with d for yesipenko
who would very much enjoy winning this
game in the final round as this would
propel him maybe all the way to fourth
place uh knight to f6 we have c for e6
knight to c3 and of course bishop to be
for the nimzo indian defense is on the
board and now uh we often say that these
are the main moves uh we've also seen f3
by uh by sam shanklin but here we have
a3 just challenging this bishop and
allowing black to double white's pawns
here so bishop captures b captures and
now not b6 like on each plate against
jordan but here the immediate c5 in that
video if you guys remember we mentioned
that this was the absolute main line we
have e3 and knight to c6 we have bishop
to d3 and now black castles we have
knights to e2 you don't want to develop
the f3 as you want to start pushing
those pawns so the knight will just get
in the way b6 preparing bishop to a6 and
then now uh white grabs the full center
with e4 we have a knight to e8 by
spanker this is the so-called capoblanca
variation uh and uh uh prague just
castles here and finally bishop to a6
with a knight to a5 coming at some point
so you can see that once again black's
plan revolves revolves around going
after that double c pawn but if you
remember the game uh jordan played
against anish that did not go so well
for black so here f4 grabbing even more
space this is now looking very very
scary
and we have to challenge this massive
center so f5 we have e captures a
captures and now d captures on c5 now
this is a weird move to see uh but it's
actually the the top move in the
position uh it's been played before many
times and both of these players know
this it's been played many many times
this is a very popular line uh to give
you an example if you play something
like d5 which makes sense you want to
grab more space in the center knight a5
and uh
white can just resign there's no way to
defend the c4 pawn and the plan actually
works for example queen a4 you defend it
we're just going to play knight to d6
hence the knight to e8 maneuver very
very uh solid by black and that there's
really no defense against capturing the
pawn and then it's just going to be a
much worse position for white so instead
we have d cap present c5 looks weird but
it works because now white will use a
lot of very important tempi to never
allow black to go after this pawn so b
captures on c5 and now bishop to e3 now
we're threatening to pick up the c5 pawn
and black has to react to this we have
d6 and now knight to g3 going after the
f5 pawn so again black has to react to
this black does not have time to
even try and go after the c4 pawn and
now you could play g uh g6 but here we
have knight to e7 defending the pawn
like this uh and then now comes queen to
f3 here there is a game where queen to
a4 was played but queen to f3 is a new
move so now it's as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game as you guys
enjoy this information very much there
we have it uh so what can black do well
he could again go g6 always very popular
we need to defend this f5 pawn at any
cost
uh but yes pengo says there is plenty of
time for that we're going to go knight
to c7 first and okay we have rook a to
b1 prague develops the rook to a nice
open b file and queen d7 connecting the
rooks we have rook f to e1 now
and finally g6 so now the pawn is very
nicely defended and you can move your
pieces uh and as you can see this is uh
so very well analyzed that both white
and black are perfectly fine here it's
very enjoyable to play this for for both
white and black and it's not easy to
find moves for either side so that's why
um it's uh well once you run out of
engine moves it's uh not all that easy
to
find the move yourself so it's not uh uh
important uh or rather
it's it's not sufficient to just
memorize the moves you also need to
understand what the position means and
where your pieces should go where it
would you know be be creative the pieces
could go so here bishop back to f2 we
claimed the e file for the rook and now
knight to c8 now the knight is coming to
b6 and maybe we can again start putting
some pressure on the c for pawn so
knights to f1 we need to have this
knight d2 or knight e3 uh idea ready to
defend the c4 pawn knight to b6 putting
pressure on the c4 pawn and knights to
e3 now prague defends it we have rook 8
to e8 black now we can say is fully
developed and now bishop to h4 it's a
very nice diagonal for the bishop much
more useful than it was on f2 uh queen
to g7 now going after the c3 pawn and
here rook b to c1 the rook is no longer
useful on the b file so rook bc one we
need to defend our pawn uh we have rook
to e6 uh and then now we have a4 and
this a4 move is such a such a great move
by probably because without it you don't
really
see how to make progress uh in the
position okay you do have black has a
maybe a weak backwards d6 pawn but other
than that you really don't uh
you really don't don't have all that
much to do with the position but here
this a4 move really is impressive
because it's a pawn sacrifice which
black really should accept if you don't
accept that a5 is coming and then we're
gonna weaken the d5 square and we really
want to win the d5 square for for our
pieces uh so here knight captures on a4
was played and now knight to d5 we claim
the d5 square for our pieces and now
black's uh uh
main question is does he want to capture
on e1 before playing bishop to b7 or he
does he want to play bishop to b7 and
allow the trait to happen on e6 so both
are both are fine uh here we have the
immediate bishop to b7 now pinning the
knight the knight cannot move uh rook
captures an e6 knight captures an e6 and
now rook to e1 putting more pressure on
the knight here and now uh the idea is
uh for example if knight to c7 you're
gonna put a lot of pressure on the
knight here and hopefully you're gonna
bring this knight back to b6 but now we
can play bishop to f6 and it's a very
very tricky line bishop captures on d5
we go for for a queen trade
bishop captures on g7 bishop captures on
f3 bishop captures an f8 king captures
an f8 and now g captures on f3 finally
knight captures on c3 and you would get
this position where white is up the
exchange but black is up two pawns and
black's pawn structure is much much
better
uh so uh white should still be better
here but not nearly enough uh to push
this for a win so this is one way to do
it with knight to c7 but
we have queen to d7 by sipenko and now
prague plays queen to g3
also
also possible here instead of going to
g3 is just the knight to e7 because this
kind of forces the
uh the
uh the end game that you've already seen
but with a much better structure for
white uh so the idea is after queen
captures any seven bishop uh
bishop captures and e7 we're going to
play bishop captures on f3 bishop
captures and f8 knight captures on f4 so
really a beautiful capture fest here
night a bishop captures on d6 knight
captures on d3 rook the e8 check first
king f7 rook to e7 check so we don't
lose our rook and now we're welcome to
pick up the bishop king of 6g captures
on f3 and you can see it's a much better
uh version of that
endgame where black is only up one pawn
and he's going to lose another one very
quickly so
that's what uh what happens here after
knight e7 but it's it's a very tricky
line what if uh what if black doesn't go
for a queen trade what if black just
moves the king king to h8 which is also
winning for white but it's very
complicated so prague first started with
queen to g3
and now
this is uh not as great as the immediate
97 because black can just now trade here
for example captures captures knight
goes here attacks the pawn uh rook to e7
and queen c8
just uh a very passive position for
black but maybe maybe maybe it's better
than what happened in the game so in the
game we have rook to f7 uh but now uh
it's just uh giving up the exchange with
the queen still on the board really so
uh queen g3 moved the queen away from
from the bishop so now knight f6 check
rook captures and bishop capture so
instead of going for that really passive
line that we discussed uh yes panko
gives up the exchange and now he will
try to do something here okay he still
has some play he has the past a pawn
it's not all that's terrible but if you
know what's coming then you will see
that the position is actually hopeless
so here we have king f7 now queen to h4
defending the bishop and also queen
captures on h7 is the threat if you
capture the bishop black loses the queen
so h5 stopping this and now bishop to g5
uh we have queen to c6 now threatening
checkmate so queen to h3 for the moment
we have to defend we have knight
captures and g5f captures and now bishop
to c8 we have to bring our bishop back
into the game queen to e3 going for some
checkmating ideas so queen back to d7
we have queen to e2 uh and now comes
queen to d8 putting pressure on the g5
pawn but now queen to a2 going after the
knight so bishop d7 defending and now
bishop to c2 and with with only within a
few moves
prague forces uh
uh well uh this position to go very very
near an end game and it's not going to
be easy for black to decline the end
game so the knight has to move now now
you could play knight captures on c3 or
go back knight to b6 was played
capturing the c3 pawn doesn't really
bring black all that much we have queen
captures on a7 and now knight c8
attacking the queen we have queen b7 uh
and now knight to e7 and here just h4
and if you look at the position now
black
just doesn't really have all that many
moves uh
i mean
the king stranded on the seventh rank
the rook really controlling this e file
the light square bishop not doing so
great for the moment but uh
black is without a move if you move the
knight even bishop to a4 can be played i
mean it's just just terrible so here
bishop the e6 was played but now rook to
a1 now probably is threatening rook to
a8 and that's it for example bishop
captures on c4 rook 8 and the black
queen is trapped there's no square for
the black queen so instead the queen to
c8 was played here is panko offers a
queen trait and prague happily accepts
with captures captures and now bishop to
b3 uh defending the pawn before uh
activating the rook so king e7 uh we
have rooked the a6 and now came to d8 we
have king f2 now prague starts bringing
the rook and king into the game king to
c7 now we have rogue back to a1
and now bishop to f7 uh we have king to
e3 now comes bishop to e6 king to f4 and
king to d8 so black repeating moves not
really
well there's no move you can play here
we have rook back to a8 by prague now
king to c7 we have rook back to a2 still
figuring out the the best possible way
to win this and the bishop back to f7 we
have rook to a1 king to d8 and now king
to e3 we have bishop to e6 and now g3
so our opponent has a light square
bishop makes sense to
move the pawn to a dark square also at
any point black might have an idea of
pushing f4 this will also prevent it so
now our king can roam freely king to c7
we have king to f4 bishop to f7 uh and
now bishop to a4 so now we're gonna
start taking away squares from uh from
black's pieces and there's not all that
much uh yes panko can do about this
knight b6 attacks the bishop but bishop
b5 again nothing really for for for
black to do here uh we have knight back
the c8 and the king to e3 now we have
bishop to e6 uh because now you are in
uh well you are in swung there is really
not all that uh all that much where you
can go uh if
you move the king away from the back
rank then we can just go in with rook to
d8 if you try something like king to b7
then we can play bishop to a6 exchange
here uh bishop for night and then our
rook against bishop is just winning and
well if you move the bishop here then we
can just bring our bishop here uh there
there's nothing you can't play if you
play a silly move like bishop to g8 then
again bishop to e8 we go after this pawn
there's no stopping it so in the game
bishop to e6 was played but now prague
just played bishop to e8 and it was in
this position on move 59 that andreas
penko resigned the game uh as there is
nothing more to be done here there's no
way to defend this uh if you try of
course the knight today knight to e7
then we play rook a7 check and after
king to d8 we just pick up the knight
and then we start collecting king
captures bishop captures here bishop
captures here and then you have just uh
well all the pawns in the world to win
this end game so after bishop d8 uh you
think resigned and another brilliant
victory for for prague uh who had a uh
well he didn't have a bad tournament but
uh the the second half of the tournament
was much much better than the first half
of the tournament and here another
example of just
how you know when the the top theory
says that uh
uh that a3 isn't all that impressive
that you know it no longer serves its
purpose there we have two tournament
victories in probably the strongest
tournament in the world uh where a3 just
just wins as it's uh well
no one was expecting it and it seems
that white was just prepared much much
better
uh so yeah
or you know just because
something
is considered a a lesser move doesn't
mean that you cannot create uh great
victories with it so so i don't forget
he here are the standings so magnus
carlsen wins the tournament with nine
and a half out of 13
a very very clean first place a point
and a half ahead of uh mamidarov and
rapport uh sharing second and third then
uh on rather not sharing mommy darwin's
second rapper is third then anish giri
uh fourth place with seven points sergey
karyakin and jordan fun four s uh with
six and a half andreas pink and fabiana
corwana you can see that if yes pango
had one he would be on seven and a half
with uh anish there uh with six yanshi
stodudda and vidi gujarati with five and
a half we have sam shanklin and
pragananda with four and a half
nilsgarden daily use uh end with
a three and a half do both but he missed
so many games that it's uh well uh
not really relevant
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and this short coverage of
the tata still masters 2022 i hope you
enjoyed that as well if you guys have
any like favorite favorites from the
final round i will consider them uh but
as i already promised we are now going
to cover uh the challengers and mainly
uh the
absolute onslaught of arjunary gaici he
completely crushed the tournament and uh
well uh i'll see how i'll cover it maybe
i'll cover a few games in a few videos
maybe in one video i will cover many
games you know anything can happen
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to robert hallowell
uh and i would like to thank isaac pinol
david kimura yuri ralachenko and the
wayfan for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the other
tata steel uh and uh well of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day